-Allo ?
-Ecoute, maman est près de toi ?
Il faut lui dire "maman c'est quelqu'un pour toi"
-Ah, c'est le monsieur de la dernière fois ?
Bon je vais la chercher. Mais je crois qu'elle est dans son bain, et je sais pas si elle va pouvoir venir.
-Dis-lui, je t'en prie, dis-lui : "c'est important"
"Mais il attend"
-Dis : tu lui as fait quelque chose à ma maman ?
Elle me fait toujours des grands signes, et elle me dit "fais croire que je ne suis pas là !"
Raconte-moi, comment est ta maison ?
Apprends-tu bien chaque soir toutes tes leçons ?
-Oh oui ! Mais comme maman travaille c'est la voisine qui m'emmène à l'école !
Et il n'y a qu'une signature sur mon carnet.
Les autres ont celles de leur papa. Pas moi.
-Oh dis-lui que j'ai mal, si mal depuis six ans
Et c'est ton âge mon enfant
-Ah non, moi j'ai cinq ans.
Mais dis :  tu la connaissais ma maman avant ?
Pourtant elle m'a jamais parlé de toi.
-Tu restes là, hein ?
-Le téléphone pleure
Quand elle ne vient pas
Quand je lui crie "je t'aime"
Mes mots se meurent dans l'écouteur
Oui le téléphone pleure
Ne raccroche pas
Je suis si près de toi avec la voix
Seras-tu aux prochaines vacances ?
A l'hôtel Beau-Rivage ?
Aimes-tu la plage ?
-Oui j'adore me baigner, maintenant je sais nager !
Mais dis donc : comment tu connais l'hôtel Beau-Rivage ?
Tu y as été toi, à Sainte-Maxime ?
-Oh dis-lui toute ma peine, combien toutes les deux
Moi je vous aime.
-Nous aime ? Mais je t'ai jamais vu moi !
Et qu'est-ce que t'as ? Pourquoi t'as changé de voix ?
Mais tu pleures !
Pourquoi ?
-Oh le téléphone pleure
Quand elle ne vient pas
Quand je lui cire "je t'aime"
Les mots se meurent dans l'écouteur
Oui le téléphone pleure
Non, ne raccroche pas
Je suis si près de toi
Avec la voix
Dis, écoute-moi
Oui le téléphone pleure
Pour la dernière fois
Car je serai demain au fond d'un train
Oh dis mais retiens-la !
-Mais elle s'en va !
Allons insiste !
Elle est partie.
Si elle est partie, alors tant pis...
-Au revoir monsieur.